là attention julie nous pas trop de
chocolat voilà puis ça manque de
moutarde
tu trouves je trouve par contre que les
bananes sont pas bien là s'écraser et la
société d'eau faut aller la chercher
n'oublie pas tiède mais cru je ne
demande comment casimir peut aimer cette
mixture moi j'ai déjà mal au coeur sans
avoir mangé j'ai cherché la russie oasis
a qu'un bonjour vous êtes là nous sommes
en train de préparer un gloubi boulga
géant pour casimir qui rentre de voyage
il doit revenir d'une minute à l'autre
il rentre d'un long voyage et il a
promis nous rapporter un souvenir de
chacun des pays qu'il a visités mais
voilà je crois qu'elles sont juste comme
il faut
rue encore métier d'appoint on les met
là dedans
les autres j'écrase il faut avouer que
c'est c'est vraiment horrible à vous
harcèle ses saucisses avec la confiture
de fraise et et puis tout le reste
tais toi je vais m'évanouir et voilà
voilà sa famille tiens tiens julie tu
tues l'emportent dans le casque moi je
préfère pu le voir
bonjour c mais voilà le grand le plus
beau
youpi au quasi vide et je peux voir une
vraie vie tu as fait un gros voyageant
excellent j'ai été dans des pays
extraordinaire
j'ai vu des choses merveilleuses que je
n'oublierai jamais tu vas nous raconter
tout ça quand ils piquent et ira bien
j'ai été en famille puis aussi aux as
j'ai oublié tous les noms tu te souviens
plus d'aucuns n'ont donc que je sais
bien que la mémoire n'est pas le fort
des casimir us le quand même là tu
exagères non mais j'ai une idée
j'ai rapporté plus un souvenir de chaque
pays et peut-être que grâce à ses
souvenirs
nous retrouverons ces endroits c'est une
très bonne idée
écoute casimir de toute façon les
enfants vont nous aider les enfants les
enfants vous ne venez avec moi bien
diedrick bien je vais vérifier si ma
surprise se porte bien
vas-y pour les enfants casimir a besoin
de vous il est parti en voyage
il nous aura apporté des cadeaux mais
malheureusement il a totalement oublié
le nom des pays alors casimir montre
nous ton premier souvenir oui oui oui un
bon ben voilà ça c'est le premier
endroit où j'habitais à qu'est ce que
c'est que ça les ensembles
c'est la tour eiffel et ça sauve à paris
et paris c'est évidemment la wii
l'apport à huy et ogier manger un petit
steak frites près du louvre et tu n'es
pas rentrer et visiter le musée du
louvre
non là tu aurais dû casimir enfin montre
nous un deuxième souvenir
bon j'ai été dans un deuxième pays oui
dont j'ai ramené ça à l'entrée moissac
casimir qu'est ce que c'est que ça des
enfants sont des castagnettes et où
trouve-t-on et castellon en espagne un
fait ça c'est sain l'espagne oui tu
étais en espagne pour deux choses oui eh
bien moi aussi
et alors prends toi prêt du musée du
prado
j'aime manger une paella que gémir tu
devrais avoir honte tu sais tu pense
qu'à manger bon montre nous à notre
souvenir alors le troisième pays où
j'étais attentes
ah oui si ça c'était une ville wheelies
appel plein choses comme ça qu'est ce
que c'est que ça montre mosson c'est une
bonbonne à fait symbolique
oui et dans lequel les pays se trouve
venise en italie
bonne nouvelle alors oui oui c'est ça
quand tu sais françois alors là je
manger des spaghettis derrière le palais
des doges l' extraordinaire dont 10 dans
casimir toit du tu pense qu'à manger un
sans arrêt où que tu ailles non un fonds
allait montrer nous à notre souvenir
casimir alors attend ensuite
ah oui voilà ça je me souviens plus très
bien à regarder cette piste que présente
cette poupée
c'est un soldat et on trouve les soldats
comme ça en angleterre
alors voila voila on la tue c'est l'âme
alors là c'est l'endroit où j'ai fait le
meilleur repas j'ai mangé de la panse de
brebis farcie avec dans la groseille et
une sauce à la menthe aulas l'a battu
c'est casimir ça ne m'étonne pas que tu
aimais s'est enfin montré autre chose
et puis le dernier pays j'ai ramené ça
lui dernier pays s'étant aussi
exactement ce sont des poupées jt
vous connaissez ouais jusqu'à la plus
petite c'est comme ça
richard et les deux petites salue la
russie en revanche a bien mangé du boeuf
du bord j'ai mis ça avec debbie nice le
bosch est un délicieux potages les
bénisse ce sont des petites crêpes très
très bonne idée
casimir dans l'autre voyage tu t'es pas
trop fatigué le cerveau mais au
contraire enfin françois cantin à
l'estomac qui descend dans les talons
hauts un on a le cerveau qui descend
dans l'estomac
c'est logique non c'est tout à fait
naturel n'est ce pas un l'estomac dans
les talons le cerveau dans l'estomac
cc c'est normal car est un délire pour
tout faire remonter le cerveau à sa
place nous avons préparé des surprises
là un gloubi boulga jai ho ho ho c'est
vraiment gentil ça alors vous savez je
n'en ai trouvé dans aucun restaurant
aucun celui-là a l'air très appétissants
bon alors il me faut deux cuillères et
tu n'as pas besoin trop cuit d'air mais
c'est bien vous qui l'avait préparé mais
réussit le alors il me faut deux autres
cuillères parce que la première règles
d'hospitalité celle et casimir us c'est
que l'on ne doit jamais mangé un gloubi
boulga avant que celui qui l'a préparé
en ai mangé une cuillère lui même
bon si tu copies plus haut
casimir